foreign
[Applause]
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love
create actual amazing relationships
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality the
Bourne best-selling author of my
daughter is my co-host today he's also
the co-host of the George Campbell it
was a big star this week on uh smart
money happy hour but Georgia's new
YouTube channel launched and uh he's a
big deal now I know he's diversifying
the Love on the internet he's he's doing
other stuff now so I that's a nice way
of saying he abandoned you he I felt a
little bit no it's great I really am
it's a it's such a great it's such a
great Channel he's done such a good job
with it so yeah the George Campbell new
YouTube channel you need to check it out
Camel with a K and check out smart money
happy hour anyway the phone number here
if you want to talk is free and some say
the advice is worth exactly what you pay
for it triple eight eight two five five
two two five thank you for jumping in
John's going to start this hour in
Oklahoma City hey John welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave and Rachel thanks so much for
taking my call I'm a big fan of the show
um my question for you guys today is
about the adjusted gross income limits
uh you know the income limit to be able
to contribute to the raw Ira
um so in 2022 like you know my wife and
I already we already contributed like
our 6 000 each you know a couple months
ago toward the 2022 year
um however we just we just filed our
taxes with our uh Tax Guy yesterday and
learned that we made it just over the
adjusted gross income limit apparently
um which I think is 214 for 2022 and
apparently we made 215 000 so when you
make too much money that happens all the
time gosh you missed it by a thousand
dollars though it's like man right there
yeah you're okay you're just gonna have
to do some gymnastics okay
um are you working with a smart investor
Pro or whether good investment broker
that's helping you do this
no sir okay uh reach out to one of our
smartvester Pros you're gonna have to
undo the Roth that you did because you
don't qualify for a Roth and so that's
gonna you're that's going to get backed
out okay and then you make an investment
you need to do what's called a backdoor
Roth but you can't do it from where you
are so you got to back out from where
you are back to even okay
now a backdoor Roth I do them and my
income is more than that so
um a backdoor Roth is where you make an
after tax
traditional IRA contribution
which is very weird Okay and then
instantaneously
30 seconds later roll it to a Roth
there's no taxes due when you do that
but you're not allowed to put money into
a Roth but you're allowed to roll money
into a Roth regardless of your income
and so what we're doing is we're opening
up an after tax which Roth is after tax
as well we're doing an after-tax
traditional and you roll it to a Roth 30
seconds later so now you've got the
money into a Roth and your your smart
investor pro at ramseysolutions.com find
somebody in your area you like that can
help you back out of the one you're in
and then set up the after tax and do the
back door roll over does that make sense
to you
yeah I think I'm following you and I can
talk with the smart investor Pro about
other questions yeah and I feel like it
sounds like to that whole idea of the
back door Roth is something that I feel
like a lot of people don't realize and
they don't they don't even know is an
option either so that's why I think
having someone in your corner an
investment professional in general is
such a great idea because they they know
these types of things and even more of
like hey how what can we do from an
estate level planning to your future to
retirement everything uh what what's
best to be able to take advantage of
these things that you may not even know
John and and frankly most people don't I
mean there's the idea of a backdoor Roth
some people have never even heard of it
so exactly it's technically a loophole
one of these days they're going to write
into one of these laws and close it this
is technically a loophole because the
you know the very purpose of having the
limits is to keep wealthy people from
having a Roth because wealthy people are
supposed to be punished in America so um
that's who we are now anyway that's tax
law so yeah that's the thing so Rachel's
exactly right it's always good to get a
Smart Vista pro at least someone like
that in your corner and here's what
you're looking for to remind you folks
out there because we've got a lot of new
people
when you're hiring a smart investor Pro
you're always looking for someone that
does not have the heart of a Salesman
instead they have the heart of a teacher
yeah because
you you the per you do not need to do
things with your money because Rachel
said to do them with your money or Dave
said do them with your money or some
goober in a suit at an investment place
it was said to do them with your money
it's your freaking money and the number
of times you have more money than the
person you're talking to is not that
unusual well and I think what's hard
with investing specifically because I
even felt this way when Winston and I
first were looking at retirement and all
that it it can be so intimidating
because there's terms there's you know
even having to follow a map of like okay
this to that and what is that again I'm
confused here I mean it's just you're
learning a whole new set of knowledge
for most people it's a whole new set of
others so to have somebody who's a
professional sitting on the other end of
the desk
that you feel like okay you're actually
a person I can talk to and I don't feel
stupid I can ask questions their job is
to educate people to teach you this not
to wag their finger and you should do it
just because they said that's right and
a big part of learning though is getting
your questions answered and learning so
much we say to the point that when you
walk out of that building that you could
explain to a fifth grader what you just
did with your money you you need the
basic knowledge the overall knowledge of
what happens and again people don't do
that in the investment World they sit
across from somebody they're intimidated
this person's saying this this and they
just say sure that sounds great yeah
whatever you want to do yeah I mean I
trust you go do and that's not the way
good idea let me tell you what that
gives you gives you when you trust
somebody you just throw it across and
you don't know what the Flip's going on
two things are going to happen to you in
your life one is every time you hear bad
news about the economy on and the stock
market on the news you're gonna freak
out because you don't know what the flip
is going on
number two you're gonna get conned
you very seldom get screwed on things
you understand
but you'll get screwed and con and let
me tell you more often than not someone
that's going to mess you over and screw
you over is not an actual con artist
they're just stupid
and their Enthusiast their enthusiastic
ignoramuses
and they've talked themselves into it
and then they talk you into it and
because somebody talked them into it
and that's all it and nobody nobody in
the whole chain decided to stop and go
how the flip does this really work
anyway
that's a good point because ignorance
is as dangerous as a con artist because
you're like oh my gosh if they really
don't understand or know what they're
doing on that end yeah or they got sold
some idea or some product and they're
trying to get you in it yeah I'm
convinced that a lot of people that sell
whole life life insurance for that they
really believe it but it's great yeah
and they're just ignorant they're just
enthusiastic ignoramuses and that they
don't last I mean 90 something percent
of people sell whole life are gone and
they they don't even last one year in
the business because once they start
figuring out that the stuff is as bad as
it is that people with honor and
integrity won't sell it
but they but but boy buddy they get all
fired up about it and and open up a Tic
Tac account you know there you go this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there why
their watch and guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality number one best-selling
author many times over host co-host of
the smart money happy hour my daughter
is my co-host today hey when folks are
calling us for advice on their money you
can hear how worn down they are
sometimes when you're living paycheck to
paycheck you feel like you're getting
your teeth kicked in been there done
that sometimes your family's falling
apart you're stuck in a cycle and the
worst part is you don't think there's
any way out well you do not have to
accept that
it does not have to be that way I know
it's scary and I know you've had the
crap beat out of you me too I know what
it looks like I know what it feels like
and sometimes it's your fault I know
what that feels like I've got a PhD in
dumb
I know what it looks like to do stupid
with zeros on the end
I've done it but we're gonna do
something special for you or maybe you
know someone that's like that or maybe
you know somebody who's just kind of
hovering around the edges of this Common
Sense Ramsay stuff this Saturday we're
doing a free live stream from our smart
conference weekend now the smart
conference is sold out
so just go ahead and get your fomo going
you missed it but we're going to stream
for free the first couple of hours and
hear me speak briefly and Rachel Cruz
and George Campbell both are going to do
their talk about how to get your income
up control your spending change your
mindset sign up for free at
ramsesolutions.com live Rachel give them
a little preview what are you gonna be
talking about a smart car no so it's
just George a nice talk right because we
have other Keynotes throughout the whole
day so yeah it's just the morning okay
perfect yeah I'm talking about the four
lies that our culture our society
believes about money so it's everything
from
the stuff you hear you know with debt
and all that but also your identity and
how much that is placed that scorecard
is so huge in America about your number
right whether it's your income what you
make how much money you have like it has
become this identity where your net
worth has become your self-worth and so
kind of unpacking that and how do you
look at money in a healthy way that's
one of the lies uh talking about that
you you're not supposed to do this alone
and again so much of our
World applauds Independence and there's
like a healthy level of Independence but
then also you can become so isolated
because you're so independent doing your
own thing versus bringing people in and
living in community and uh John Delaney
talks a lot about friendships and
relationships and how key that is to
having a holistic Life So that obviously
plays into your money too so we can talk
about that so uh it's a really fun talk
I'm really excited about it it's gonna
be it's gonna be great so George
Campbell Rachel Cruz both talking and
teaching money first thing in the
morning on Saturday morning this coming
Saturday day after tomorrow the sold out
smart conference you can join for free
for the first two lessons just uh well
the first two lessons on Saturday
morning anyway
um
just jump in at ramsaysolutions.com free
and you can register
slash events live it is free whoa It's a
lot about that mic it's live are you
sure it says okay yeah I'm looking at a
monitor over there okay that says slash
life yeah there we go okay I dropped my
copy but there we go
we got lots of places figure it out it's
at ramsaysolutions.com
don't miss this live stream and spread
the word put it out on your social tell
people it's completely freaking free so
if you don't like it just turn it off
but you're gonna love it all right Lisa
is with us Lisa is in Jacksonville
Florida hi Lisa welcome to the Ramsay
show
well thank you Dave good afternoon how
are you guys better than we deserve
what's up
so my husband and I we have a blended
family
um he has two children from a previous
marriage and I have four children from a
previous marriage and three
grandchildren
of late uh each of the children for
various reasons and in different
circumstances have gotten themselves
into situation where they need help
which is understandable
The Last of The Brood are 17 year old
twins who will be graduating high school
this year and the oldest would be my 31
year old daughter
and her three children and so we've got
everything in between
we're trying to figure out where to draw
the line to help them and not enable
them I don't believe that money is the
answer to everything that's just not how
I view Money
and I don't want them to think that
either and we are certainly not
independently wealthy
um we work very hard for what we have so
what was the last request that spurred
this call
yeah
hello sorry what was the last request
from a kid that spurred this call
21 got into some trouble at school
and it looks like there's going to need
to be money paid out and my oldest
daughter got into an automobile accident
where the car was totaled and then she
had to admit to me that Not only was she
behind on the car payments but did not
pay the insurance
okay uh your your youngest getting
criminal act are you middle one criminal
activity
misdemeanor yep she she got in trouble
and it looks like there may be some
restitution that might be being
requested she's a junior in college
like how much
undetermined I really won't know
anything about ten thousand one thousand
I'm going to say maybe five okay
uh Lisa my knee jerk is which granted I
have three little ones at home and I'm
realizing
after you experience parenting you have
different opinions on stuff so so Rachel
in 10 years may have a different opinion
Lisa I'm gonna humbly say that so to me
the 21 year old are you still are they
still under you financially your
daughter are you guys paying for school
are you helping her out or is she
completely independent financially
she is not completely independent with
all of my children I've tried to follow
the same protocol as soon as she turned
18 I had the cell phone put into her
name she pays for that I just turned
over the vehicle that I was allowing her
to drive in her name uh within the last
two or three months I put the insurance
in her name and she pays that if she
needs help with her bills
um she knows that she can come to me and
I'm willing to help out because I know
that school is becoming more taxing sure
but those it's part of being an adult
you know yeah no absolutely because for
the 21 year old with with a whole
criminal thing and you're a junior in
college all of that for some reason I
have as a parent I feel the need to to
to step into that situation
um faster than I would the 31 year old
in the car payment and the insurance
because to me I'm like the why why on
both of these is always the question I
want to ask so you know for the Junior
and college so there's obviously behave
there's choices that are being made in
life that are not wise so there's a big
thing there that's not necessarily a
money issue it's become a money issue
because she may have to pay five
thousand dollars or whatever it may be
so you helping pay the financial side of
that while walking with her through life
and saying hey how can I walk beside you
as your mom and love you well and
understand what caused the situation
like that's one thing for me the 31 year
old I'm like okay so then why are you
behind on your car payment why are you
behind on your insurance because that's
an adult Pro like that's a to me like
that's a that's an adult problem like
you you didn't pay something that you're
supposed to be paying and so why is that
is it because you don't have the money
is it because you're not keeping up with
payments and all that so asking that why
question is really big for me Lisa to
understand am I enabling or am I helping
but that 21 year old for some reason my
heart was just like whoo that's not a
money problem yes it's become a money
problem but there's life choices that
are occurring there that I would want to
step into fast the level of help that we
would extend
would be
based on really two things
how repentant are they and repentance
means turning away
so we were walking towards stupid or we
were running towards stupid we not only
stopped but now we're running the other
way that is repentance
I'm never going to do this again I'm
completely changing whatever behavior
that caused this in either of these
cases and I'm running the other way I
just need some help this one time to
turn the corner that is repentance if
that is not there in Spades I mean like
enthusiastic repentance just let them
bathe in it
let them bathe in the pain if that is
there and then you can figure out how
you can on a one-time basis help them
move towards smart from dumb with a
little bit of cash on a one-time basis
then that's good where we just
continually are bailing them out that's
enabling or where you're bailing out
someone who's not repentant then you
want good things for them more than they
do and only Lisa if you guys have the
money you said we're not financially
yeah you don't have the cash you can't
help sorry stop sorry yeah nope this is
the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today a and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host it is financial literacy month
and we're celebrating the incredible
work of incredible teachers that help us
with foundations in personal finance and
all the work they're doing our finance
foundations and personal finance
curriculum for high schoolers teaching
them common sense about money is now in
48 percent of the high schools that
means there's 52 percent that don't have
it that's a problem because everyone
should be learning this stuff we have
one of our foundations financial
literacy is an important subject we
don't talk about it with our kids enough
that's why we created this foundations
of personal finance curriculum it's now
been taught as I said in 48 of the high
schools over 6 million students have now
been through this we've got one of the
foundation's teachers on the show with
us today to celebrate this month Orlando
is a teacher in Memphis Tennessee hey
Orlando how are you Dave I'm doing great
it was great to talk to you all my
students are excited that I'm talking to
Uncle Dave and B Rachel Cruz
Uncle Dre Uncle Dave and cousin Rachel
there we go there you go I love it so
what what school do you teach at Orlando
so I teach at Memphis University School
right here in Memphis Tennessee not far
down the road from you we're a private
high school of about roughly 700 kids uh
College Preparatory School uh big
academic Excellence good Athletics and
just always teaching the boys how to do
right here
very cool so it's a boys school
it's all males yes sir okay cool very
cool you'll have it that's interesting
all right so how long have you been
teaching foundations
uh Foundation the literal curriculum
that you have put out we've only done
really for the last three years one of
our great alumni decided to donate it to
the school but Dave I've been teaching
principals for at least the last 10
years here at the school I listened to
show for a lot of years and the honest
video I've memorized pretty much all of
your lines and all of your curriculum
and so we've had it in some way shape or
form for about the last 10 years and the
kids absolutely love it that's so great
so Orlando if it's been over a decade of
teaching just the principles in general
do you have students that come back
after they graduate or they go to
college or even after college and they
come back and they're like oh my gosh
what you talked about with money in our
class I used it and there's like success
stories around it
son who's 24 now
really took to it and he started his own
Financial blog uh it was it's a
financial literacy blog and what was
funny about his first post in it was I
had to sit there and listen to
unsolicited lectures about Dave Ramsey's
principles but it finally took and he's
on path to being a millionaire one of my
best success stories young man named JJ
Johnson currently a senior at Vanderbilt
he had been at one of my summer camps I
worked with a group called uh Rising
together foundations and what I do is
financial literacy for young kids JJ was
a counselor sat there listened to it and
took the knowledge and said man I got to
do something that Vanderbilt got
together with a couple of his friends
Gabby Martin and Kevin West and they
started money readers right there at
Vanderbilt because he saw Vanderbilt
students just taking loans left and
right not knowing how to manage their
money and not understanding compound
interest so JJ got together with them
and started that group and I get young
people all the time alone calling me a
lot of times they're asking advice hey
I'm getting ready to open a Roth IRA
what do you think that's amazing
I'm like a doctor I'm on call just call
me I'm ready to go to talk to you you're
a good teacher that's amazing now you
are a great teacher we need people like
you all over the place in America thank
you for doing this and uh it's um yeah
it's more of a thankless job than it
used to be to be a teacher these days
um and uh and it shouldn't be so we we
admire you we appreciate you all of you
that are teachers we uh it's an
incredible incredible calling okay so
you're in the classroom with Juniors and
seniors and you're going through the
Ramsey personal finance foundation's
curriculum
what's the number one question you get
from the kids
okay so it's a million of them but what
it is Dave that they love and you do it
all the time is the power of the
compound interest and you'll allow me
I'm gonna give you a quick example I did
this the other day the I I do the car
example and they love to see the car
example one guy purchased a brand new
car in America right now it's 49.5 if he
has good credits about nine percent 72
months that's 900 bucks a month you're
gonna pay 64 000. it's going to be worth
about 18 after seven years I thought 46
000 loss then I take guy B and I say he
drove Uber delivered pizzas scraped
together 2 000. he takes the same 900
payment now he's not gonna be able to
put all of it into a mutual fund
obviously because he needs a sink fund
for repairs I know this because I've
done it before 200 a month for the sync
fund for repairs 300 a month to replace
the car in two years you'll have seven
thousand to replace it in two years and
another seven thousand replace it so and
then the other 400 goes into a mutual
fund that outperforms the s p now you
got a 50 22 000 gain versus a forty six
thousand dollar loss now my math that's
a hundred thousand dollar opportunity
cost going to the guy that bought the
two thousand dollar car and the main
difference between the two of them the
only other difference one Gap look to go
to the stoplight so when they see that
math they go nuts and they're like you
Mr K tell us the next thing because
that's amazing I want to see the next
way that I get compound interest working
for me numbers work because I've done
them in my own life yeah and I'm on page
for millionaire status even though I
didn't start doing your stuff until I
was 40. wow so the stuff works and the
kids love it because they know it works
Orlando thank you thank you for being
who you are for being the kind of man
you are the kind of teacher you are uh
and thank you for teaching the
foundations and personal finance
curriculum you're a hero man you're
absolutely amazing I think what's so
refreshing about doing the high school
even that example of using a brand new
car versus you know a two thousand
dollar car
is high school students it's almost like
they haven't been uh
persuaded in culture and in life
brainwashed brainwashed into believing
again that it's like oh my gosh if I
have a great car I have to have a great
car there's something about the car that
is such an identity piece to us as
adults and they haven't experienced that
yet so they it's almost like this Purity
that they're looking at these numbers
because they're like they haven't felt
that pressure in a really deep way
besides as much as teenagers compare
which I know they do but on in a really
deep way so I'm like it's so fun to hear
16 17 year olds be like oh yeah well of
course of course before they're tainted
with the idea that like no you have to
have a nice car you have to have a great
car you have to have a great car and
that's part of your quote unquote
success so it just it just shows that
they they are sponges and these high
schoolers they they are they're getting
it Winston and I were downtown last
night for this concert event thing
um and we were in the parking garage and
this young girl I mean she probably was
college or early 20s and yeah she
stopped me and she's like I took your
personal finance class oh my gosh you
know so she was just telling me how how
great it was like I still use this stuff
today and I was like oh that's so great
so wow that's cool so they're just
sponges I'm like so parents out there
that's encouragement to you to start if
you're not talking to your kids talking
to your teenagers about money when some
of you businesses in the areas you could
do with that teachers yes local or local
entrepreneur sponsored that class paid
for it for that high school to get this
class and get it in the classroom man
you talk about investing that's good
investing right there that's awesome
stuff so we're we're celebrating as we
said uh the financial literacy month we
do this with a teacher appreciation
giveaway if you are a in class teacher
of any kind I don't care if you teach
kindergarten
through K through 12. if you teach in a
class you're a teacher
we want you to enter the Ramsey teacher
appreciation giveaway no purchases
necessary sponsored by the Army National
Guard
one teacher randomly is going to be
drawn and will win a five thousand
dollar vacation of your choice we're
going to write a check of five thousand
dollars to whoever you say you want to
go on vacation with and two more
teachers are going to win three thousand
dollar vacations each because Lord knows
a good teacher needs a vacation so there
we go check it out go to
ramsesolutions.com teacher to enter if
you're not a teacher and your loved one
one that you had as a student or maybe
you're married to a teacher or maybe
your brother or sister is a teacher or
whatever tell them to go to
ramseysolutions.com teacher to enter
this will end at the end of the month
April is financial literacy month this
is our teacher appreciation giveaway
brought to you by the Army National
Guard
very cool stuff these teachers are
amazing they're amazing and we need to
salute them we need to back them we need
to support them and this is just one
little way we can do it here at Ramsey
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Ty
open phones are triple eight eight two
five five two two five Sean is with us
in Washington D.C hey Sean welcome to
the Ramsay show
and Rachel thanks for taking my call I
actually have a two-part question
related to how military retirement and
VA disability factor into retirement
savings okay and uh just just a little
background my wife and I are both
retired military we're debt free and
we're on baby steps four and six we have
between our military retirement pensions
and our VA disability it's about a
hundred and ten thousand a year and then
we both we both currently work and bring
in an additional 125 000 in income from
those jobs wonderful artists yeah our
assumption has been that we invest 15 of
that retirement and VA disability even
though it's quote unquote a pension
um so that was my first question is that
correct according to the baby steps
well I mean the purpose of baby step
four putting 15 away for retirement is
to build wealth
right um and so uh obviously the more
you put in the build wealth category the
more wealth there's going to be
so um I I uh I would tend towards
agreeing with you in other words because
I want you to build a big old hairy nest
egg and you have a great income I don't
know why you couldn't save I mean you
make 250 000 between all of these
sources and I don't know why you
couldn't save thirty thousand dollars or
forty thousand dollars it's you should
be able to and you're going to want that
um it's not as if you need it to eat
it's just a matter of Building Wealth at
this point to be able to change your
family tree to be generous to enjoy and
those kinds of things but this is not a
oh if you don't say if you're going to
be eating dog food at retirement because
you're not I mean you've served your
country thank you for that and your
country is giving you a wonderful uh
military retirement good we should and
um you know you've been you guys served
and that that's the deal you made and so
yeah that's good and then you got the
extra income on top of that I would I
would save out of everything 15 because
when we get to baby step seven and the
house has paid off we don't have a 15
percent rule then we say you know save
all you can invest all you can give all
you can and live all you can we want to
load it all up
and so that that leads me to the second
part of my question is is there ever a
time you know this income the VA VA
disability and military retirement are
essentially until we pass away is there
ever a time where we say
um
we don't need to invest it anymore or
once we're retired and enjoying our
retirement life do we stop or is do we
keep going forever I don't think you're
going to need it
okay
I mean you you again you know you're
going to have a pile of money you're
gonna have these wonderful retirement
benefits and you can continue to invest
now if you do not have an earned income
meaning all you have is military
retirement and disability you cannot do
401ks in Roth IRAs you have to have an
earned income to do those sorry I'll be
limited on that but could you just put
it in mutual funds sure you could I just
don't think it's ever going to be a
thing where
you're ever having to make a choice
between a good life and continuing to
invest I think both of those are going
to coexist because you've done a
wonderful job
yeah our dog our dog he heard me just
mention money and he ran off because
we're I don't say we're gazelle intense
now I'm paying off the house but we're
definitely white-tailed deer intent
we're working hard to get our house paid
off so we can get the uh so we can
really get into
I think that's accurate I've seen both
in the wild and whitetail deer are
definitely a lazier gazelle
that's very cool you and your family we
appreciate you Asher's in Oklahoma City
hey Asher what's up
hey
sure
decide if I want to do step three B to
save our house or if I should serve four
which I already did and then save on top
of that
um so when when are you looking to move
when do you want to buy a house
well I'm renting right now
I know do you I'm not looking are you in
a place I can afford it I guess yeah are
you in a position meaning life stage
wise that you're going to be staying in
Oklahoma City for a bit do you see
yourself being there permanently for you
know multiple years at least for the
foreseeable future yeah okay okay when
do you want to buy
when do you think you're actually going
to be ready to buy what's your plan
[Music]
didn't do uh maybe step four at all
to save up five percent
recorded my take home and the 15-year
fix what do you make
uh 67 base
what do you make maybe 77 last year okay
are you married
nope okay
why is it going to take you six years to
save up a down payment that's ridiculous
uh well
um 185 000 house if I did my numbers on
and to be able to keep it under a
quarter of my take-home I would need to
save up like 100k
no you must have done something wrong
that doesn't work uh you know you can
afford more than 85 000 mortgage on a
15-year fixed a quarter of your take
home when you make a 80 75 or 80 000 a
year so you messed up something on the
math dude
um yeah and so that changes the formula
so I I think what you got to do is you
gotta what I do might do is just holler
at Churchill Mortgage and start talking
to them about how this is going to work
exactly what you've got to do get some
real numbers and
um if you're if your take home if you've
got a bunch of crap coming out of your
check other than taxes that's not what
we mean by take-home pay
what we mean by take-home pay is after
tax
okay so if you've got like an 800 health
insurance thing or child support or a
car payment going to your credit union
or something like that yeah and you're
calling that take-home pay then that
might mess up the numbers but with what
you make you can qualify for more than
you're talking about and so then what
you've got to do is you've got to you
know because we're at a six percent rate
right now roughly that's what we're
hovering right now on fixed rates on a
15-year yeah and so 6.8 uh not just
break uh yeah I was just running his
numbers yeah okay retext everything so I
had 6.3 at the beginning of the week
maybe it jumped up but um anyway that's
uh uh but right in there and the point
here is that uh you know you get your
numbers right and then you start
figuring out how you're going to do your
down payment but dude you do not have to
have a hundred thousand dollars down on
185 000 house that's just not that is
not going to be where you're in no
because this is even saying you know
because we say for first-time home
buyers too
that you know the range really is from
five to twenty percent is kind of like
that ideal 20 is great to avoid PMI but
if you're a first-time home buyer it can
you know it can be as low as five
percent now don't quote me on this this
is just I just pulled up a mortgage
calculator real fast it's looking like a
down pay for a 15 year no not the down
payment the payment he was concerned
about getting the payment low enough
that it was a fourth that was going to
hit take-home pay yeah but his monthly
yeah it would be a sixteen hundred
dollar
uh
a sixteen hundred dollar payment on what
185 Grand on 175 is what I put in a down
payments eight thousand seven hundred
and fifty dollars five percent I mean so
he's gonna have to put down more than
that because 1600 is going to be more
than a fourth of his taking something
700 yeah that's not what I'm talking
about but it's not going to be a hundred
thousand dollars down either right to
get the payment down low enough so
um it you know you may have to have 30
down or 40 down or something like that
and uh and during this time I assure
your your income is going to be coming
up yes over those years that's such a
good point
um but it but I will say because people
they do get frustrated with our house
formula saying that it's very
conservative there's you know when you
when you run the numbers 30 years yeah
yeah I know that's but I'm just saying
for 30 years I've been afraid no I know
I know I I felt it as a as a Wee child
that they've been frustrated I know uh
but the but the why behind it though is
what ends up happening is that home
ownership the quote-unquote American
dream robs so many people from their
income that you you pay so much out on a
on a mortgage that you don't have the
margin to invest and to give and to save
to do all these other things with your
money because so much of it goes to the
mortgage so that's because you're pushed
to buy just because you're pissed about
interest rates are you pissed about
house prices or you're pissed about Dave
Ramsey none of those things give you a
pass on math math will still kick your
butt so you don't get a pass
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where people build wealth
where we help people build wealth and
people do build well and we help them
with their work and we help them with
their relationships open phones here at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author my
daughter is my co-host today triple
eight eight two five five two two five
smart conferences this weekend here on
the Ramsey campuses in our brand new
Ramsey Events Center it is the first
public event completely sold out there
will be about three thousand of our
closest friends hanging out with us all
weekend it starts tomorrow night and
prior to tomorrow at six o'clock to our
time in Nashville it's sold out as I
said but we are going to broadcast this
show from one to four to central time
from the stage
of the Ramsey Event Center
which is a bit of a trip I was up there
doing the sound check and it's it's an
interesting process we've got here but
we're going to be doing this show for
three hours from the stage uh We've lots
of people have gotten the tickets that
they're free to come in and so and I
think there may be a few more for those
of you out in the lobby if you want to
come watch the show in the event center
tomorrow but let's say you're out of
town or you're like doing something else
you don't want to come over here to this
campus or whatever
it's going to be on on YouTube uh live
straight up straight through and so
you'll get the you'll get to see what
the because normally it's delayed
YouTube Right explained by a little bit
but you're gonna get to see the the
interior of the event center and the
staging and all that stuff so tune in if
you don't normally tune in live I tune
in from one to four Central tomorrow we
will be live streaming the Ramsey Show
uh on everything but certainly the best
way if you want to pick it up uh for
free is on YouTube and we'd love to have
you come and join us Daniela is with us
in Dallas hi Daniela how are you
hey
could you Michael I'm so grateful to be
on today well honored to have you how
can we help
yes so I'm wondering if I should sell my
condo because the HOA is really high at
6.50 and I live in Dallas Texas and I
want to touch the salad and just pay off
the rest of my dad wow watch the HOA so
high
what's the condo worth
um I think
okay I'm um
as a homeowner
uh if I'm you I am by the end of the day
I want some information from these
people
what they're doing with the money yeah
that's asinine what is going on a 250
000 condo with a 650 I mean that sounds
like a two or million dollar property or
three million dollars right exactly and
it's like I'm in Texas like what's going
on
well I mean you could do it stupid's in
Texas too but um but you know I mean wow
yeah yeah I want to find out what's
under this and you know did they jacket
how long have you been there
um since 2018 so I started out with 450
and they just literally putting up like
100 every year so now we're at 6.50 and
so these I have these like assessments
that we would pay every other month so
now they just tacked it all together
every month every month right
are they doing a major renovation like
parking lot replacement or roof
replacement or something I had
I haven't like run for office I'm not
the only one concerned about it
um and she's at this point I just feel
like these years people have been
complaining nothing have happened so I'm
like I don't even own the land like is
it worth continuously
you know owning this condo or should I
step out of it well the problem you've
got to find out about this anyway
because this devalues your conda
nobody wants to buy 250 000 condo with
this ridiculous HOA fee so it's going to
make your condo not worth as much
right so you've got to find out what the
Flip's going on to having maybe it's
going on for one more year because
they're building up a war chest to go do
the roofs or something like that but you
don't have to be by bylaws very
transparent oh yeah you have the right
to know exactly where the money is yeah
you have to be able to they're supposed
to document everything so yeah you
should be able to pull yeah I want to
see a copy of the financials and explain
to me why the flip this is double what
it should be in minutes from the
meetings I mean all of that I think you
you need to pull all of that and see
yeah see what's going on because that is
that is strange but just say for your
sake Danielle like say it is like well
sorry this is just what it is and
you know I don't know yes I would sell I
would get out of there because it's
being poorly managed yes
I can hear this I like that okay I'll do
the first step but yeah because you've
got to have you've got to have an
explanation for your buyer otherwise I
don't want to buy it if I'm the buyer I
don't I don't want to walk into this
yeah because that's a red flag I mean if
you just say I have high and you mean 25
dollars high but this sounds to me like
it's double what it should be
um I mean we own a property for instance
that the HOA fees uh include a golf
course and several other things and it's
only 750 and the properties in that
neighborhood are uh five to twenty
million dollars
just to give you an idea that's how
stupid this number is
so um that that's just nuts and and so
you know and there's a lot of amenities
built into that's what I'm saying like
country club type stuff yeah schools and
clubhouses and yeah yeah yeah and so
into that it's an entire development
yeah little city so obviously you're
going to pay more but for a 250 000
condo to be paying as much as you're
paying HOA yeah that's just nuts so I'm
going to want to know more and the
problem is is that
that's I hate HOAs I just hate them this
is such a free spirit thing to say I
don't even know how much art Winston
pays cars it's not much it's always in
our butt
I know but no I'm sorry we don't live
with a community with a golf course
that's not what the point was the point
is you guys are in a very efficiently
run neighborhood Winston and I have
talked about this it was not it was not
the the fact that you're living in the
slumsy obviously not not as expensive as
mine
so uh
yeah oh my gosh
oh you free Spirits out there it's okay
if you have a nerd spouse and they run
every little thing I just was taking my
head I was like I need to go to my every
dollar budget and see how much our HOA
fees are because I'm like I don't even
yeah I'm just I'm we're members of a
whole bunch of HOAs and none of them are
fun so um none of them you just don't
like being told what to do
I don't like paying you know and then
being told what to do that's exactly
right by people who don't have anything
else to do with their lives you should
write that for your board no thank you
cp-h-o and you should you should I have
found to never waste my time serve your
community
serve your community
is the way to give in life and Dave
we'll have to find another way to be a
good way to Surf we'll have to find
another way for president day for
president you might see signs okay
throughout 2024 irrigated serve your
country you sound like the OC I'm more
likely to serve my country
and both of them are not they're one of
the housewives one of the intros the OC
is like you know gated community all
bougie you should be you should be a
part of the Real Housewives too you'll
fit right in I should be a real
housewife or use
in that cup
what are you drinking over here this
water is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America hey if you like the show we need
some help from you we need you to share
the show you can do that if you're a
podcast listener or a YouTube listener
by clicking the share link or sharing
the link either one however you want to
do that the share button do all that we
need you to subscribe and follow the
show in whatever format you're taking
the show and you can share the show if
you're listening on talk radio we get
680 talk radio stations Across America
and if you're doing that just tell
somebody where you're listening or if
you're watching on TBN tell them you're
doing that let people know we're here
please and of course you can rate the
show we need five star ratings one star
doesn't help Mama said if you had
anything nice to say don't say anything
at all just move yourself along if you
hate the show go on watch something else
do something else it's okay we're okay
with that but uh leave us a five star
that helps And subscribe and follow and
share if you do all of those things that
moves us forward in the algorithms and
people learn about us that didn't know
we were here and were able to help more
people and that's why we're here so
thanks for hanging out with us Jorge is
with us in Orlando Florida hi Jorge how
are you
hi I'm doing pretty good how are you
better than I deserve what's up
all right so uh I have no debt I'm
getting married in June
um I go after the wedding is to buy a
house after one year congratulations
thank you is it smart to put the
emergency fund and how fun in a high
yield savings account so it could grow a
little
um yes I think it's a great place to put
it yeah high yield savings accounts
um actually are getting a little bit
better even than money markets depending
on your bank
um and so yeah I think a high yield
savings account is a is a perfect place
to keep an emergency fund that's where
we keep ours Jorge my husband and I uh
and then we have another one that's in
the same account that we use for
short-term savings so that's basically
exactly what what we personally do and
what we recommend to people so you're
you're doing it exactly right so
congrats on the wedding and it's smart
to wait a year I think you're being
really wise in that decision as well so
uh yeah you guys are starting off on a
really great foot here here's the
warning
yes you should do that and yes that's
wise and I completely agree but here's
the warning okay you're getting four
percent instead of one percent
on ten thousand dollars it's four
hundred bucks
right
translation
whoopee
what's important is what's important is
that you're paying attention that's
important what's important is that you
have an emergency fund for emergencies
not going into debt for that and uh and
that you've earmarked it for that and
you don't touch it for anything else
right and all of those wise things are
what are going to cause you to build
wealth oh and by the way the money
that's going to be in your house fund to
buy a house with is not going to be
because of the interest rate on this
it's going to be because you put money
in there because 400 is not going to get
you a house
yeah yeah now the plan is to put 50 uh
50s for 50k for house fund and then
it'll probably be 18K for emergency fund
yeah but if you put in 50k in a year
um the amount of interest you make in
that year while you're putting in 50K
is nothing compared to the fact that
Jorge is a genius and put in 50k so
you're the secret sauce not the investor
right that's what I'm trying to tell you
yeah and I want you to everybody to
grasp that that the important the reason
money is in a short-term savings account
is because you put the money in there
not because it earned interest because
it doesn't earn enough interest it's not
there mathematically to do that yeah so
all you're doing is being wise with a
very short term
play that's all you're doing and that
that is a good thing and you're very you
are way ahead of the curve dude every
everything you brought up you are doing
it correctly that's right and the fact
that you know the big purchase is coming
in you know less than three years that
you know you're going to write a check
so but for a lot of people though
because inflation is so high
you know I I if you had a lot of money
it just sitting in a high yield savings
though without a plan You're Gonna Lose
so it's not a long-term cash is not like
in that in that regard you make forward
you're not even keeping up yeah but if
you but you want to be able to get to it
quickly which is the emergency fund key
it's more like Insurance versus an
Investments and putting money in the
market was something that you know
you're gonna be pulling out in a year
two years even three years there's just
some risk with the volatility of the
market so having it somewhere safe that
you can get to is always a great plan
Tara is in Harpers Ferry West Virginia
hi Tara how are you
I'm doing well
better than I deserve what's up
so at the moment
I'm on Boundary by the year ago and paid
off uh twenty thousand dollars in debt
good for you and I've been at the moment
I'm trying to move out of my parents
house but I have no fit and everything
and it requires you to have credit no it
doesn't I do no it doesn't the places
around here everyone's telling me no
they don't I need a credit score no they
don't
I don't believe you Anthony O'Neill that
was a Ramsay personality called 20
apartment complexes in our immediate
area
and two of them required a credit score
if you didn't have a credit score
because you're moving out of your
parents house and you were 100 debt free
and you had an emergency fund five of
them asked for because there was no
credit score and additional deposit but
only two out of 20 required a credit
score or they would not rent for you
rent to you you have not checked you've
just talked to your friends
yeah
I've been through Zulu I've tried to
talk to people around here I've used and
talked to Realtors there did you call
apartment complexes and ask them on the
phone to the manager if you could rent
their apartment without a credit score
you're moving out of your parents house
and you have an emergency fund and you
have the deposit and you have a job
yes the few that was going to let me
require the cosigner and you talk badly
about no I would not do a co-signer I
wouldn't rent from them
how many did you call that told you that
really tell me the truth
um each week I look through Zulu and
call about 50 around me because it's a
large area in Martinsburg and Harpers
Ferry
Tara I don't want to be disrespectful
but I you're doing something wrong here
because it's you what you have found is
completely opposite of what we found as
we've researched this we have sat and
physically called from Ramsey and said
I'm moving to Nashville from another
place from my mother's basement I don't
have a credit score I have an emergency
fund and I have a full-time job making
this do you require and all uh very few
of them require this I don't know how
you managed to find 50 a week that
require it when we can't even find one
so something's wrong with this equation
yeah because for
because for a majority of time if you
have proof of income if
security deposit in cash
sometimes they make you front first
month's rent last month's rent you know
there's they usually do yeah there's
that credit score all of that that
you're going to have to to provide but I
would yeah Tara I mean I wouldn't and
here's the deal right so say it is that
extreme then keep moving out keep moving
out your circle further further further
you know find an individual landlord
that owns a property that is a is a real
person and is not some corporate owner
of uh because the only people that
require this are corporate idiots
real humans that are landlords all they
want to see is that you can pay the bill
and you know like for instance I've got
a bunch of real estate if you came to
rent from us and you had no credit score
but you had proof of job and a good down
payment and um and you you know and
you're moving from another city we can
verify where you used to live whatever
it is you know we're going to do the
background checks and everything but if
we can find all of that then we don't I
couldn't care less if you have a credit
score all I want is my money is the
landlord
and so and that's a lot of individual
landlords as well so you may need to
find that instead of some corporate
thing uh I think there's something else
in your formula that I misunderstood
from you or you didn't represent
correctly one of the two because what
you're telling me is just not happening
out there it just doesn't happen so it's
Theory people talk about on the internet
but when we actually call apartment
complexes we did not find that
and it's on YouTube Anthony calling
Anthony O'Neill was here he was calling
find it on YouTube right now yeah he's
calling apartment complexes nope nope
nope nope nope yep I mean that was it
was just over and I thought it would be
half of them I was a little shocked when
you were saying nope nope that means you
don't need a credit score you don't need
a credit score don't need a credit score
don't need a credit score don't need a
credit score that was the answer over
and over and over again this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsey trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Randy
and Audra are with us hey guys how are
you doing great how are you welcome
where do you guys live uh Whitewater
Wisconsin very cool welcome to Nashville
thank you and how much debt have you
paid off a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars I love it and how long did this
take uh 29 months good for you your
range of income during that two and a
half years uh 140 000 to 180 000. cool
what do y'all do for a living I'm a
contractor slash handyman okay and I
work for the insurance okay
you work to get a free insurance I'm
actually a technical designer so okay
good for you well done what kind of debt
was the 130. it was a beautiful house in
Whitewater Wisconsin
everything no payments anywhere in the
world not a thing congratulations you
guys that is fabulous what's this house
worth uh about 550. I love it how much
of you guys got saved in retirement uh
we're about 350 with in retirement and
we have some other property we own so
we're probably just over a million good
for you looking at Baby Steps
millionaires too way to go guys all
right tell us what happened two and a
half years ago made you decide you're
gonna do this Ramsey stuff and pay off
the house well I work by myself quite a
bit so I was looking for some new
podcast to listen to and Audra said well
why don't you listen to the Dave Ramsey
Show I'm like
okay
well after I listen to it I'm like you
know what I think there was an
underlying meaning be hurt behind her
asking me to listen to that right I mean
I told him she's sneaky that way yeah
he's a free insurance girl yeah you
listen to the podcast in literally three
days later said
we have to do this we have to do this
right now I drop everything we're doing
this Have you listened to the podcast
we're doing this and I said yes honey
that's such a great idea yeah she's such
a good you're so wise it's always better
when it's my idea though
okay so you were obviously you were more
on board beginning you had what was it
that kind of roped you in that you were
like here listen to this because there's
a lot of spouses that say I want to do
this but my husband or my wife you know
they're hesitant so we do tell them tell
them to listen to the podcast because
maybe that'll help my family was very
into it maybe 10 years prior okay and I
had mentioned to him at that time and he
was like
um yeah yeah not really sure not ready
yeah exactly and I said
the opportunity will come around again
okay so did y'all have any debts besides
the house or was that really the thing
that was
um we did have some Consumer Debt okay
which we we took care of pretty quickly
okay um and then after that we
yeah we refinanced in 2019 and you know
got one of those nice low rates that
they were offering at the time and you
know all your friends are telling you
well you know don't pay off your house
because you know that money is going to
make you more money than paying off your
house and I'm like you know what I'm
getting older I want to make sure that
that house is gone by the time I'm ready
to retire so I can retire whenever I
want now so how old are you two uh I'm
56. I'm 54. okay oh and your baby
stuff's millionaires you're paid for
house worth five six hundred thousand
dollars how's that feel oh it's
fantastic amazing
have you ever been debt free since you
got married
um if if we were it was right when we
first got married but it was probably
for a very short period of time for 10
minutes and then we figured out we
decided we probably needed a car or
something back then so I'm stupid but
okay but you were living pretty frugally
and under control to start with because
you didn't have a big mortgage you
didn't have a bunch of Dad no and so you
just reach over and smack the house and
you're done right no when we first got
married I just said we need to have a
savings uh like emergency fund and I'm
like what the heck's an emergency fund
but little that I know she knows way
more than I do so okay so you guys I
mean you to to a degree you were pretty
intense I mean you guys lived on half of
your income basically to do this in two
years right uh did the kids feel the the
sacrifice do you feel like it was a lot
of sacrifice or do you feel like oh no
we like I still had a great because
there are support groups for teenagers
out there that have been doing the Dave
Ramsey stuff we think they were fine I'm
not so sure I'm crying
but at the end of the day as parents
yeah worth it yes and they got on board
rather quickly when they saw how excited
we were about it and that it wasn't
we weren't taking things from them we
were actually giving them freedom to do
with their money what they wanted to
instead of somebody else saying you know
you owe me yeah so that's the way to go
you guys I'm proud of you thank you
thank you very much outside of your
immediate family who were your biggest
cheerleaders who was saying this is
smart you should do it
um I think both of our immediate
families are I mean our parents and
stuff were pretty supportive we didn't
tell a lot of people outside of that but
um you know most of them were pretty
supportive yeah good they were happy we
were doing it not them I guess but
yeah so what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt-ish
for me it was the budget I just had no
clue where it was going
so writing it down using
um every dollar app was just
instrumental again there was crying
involved trying to figure out how to use
it and just wrapping my head around
budgeting
but like I said three months in we were
like pros at it so and still doing it
today
um for me it's mostly being patient with
the process
um I tend to want to do things really
fast and get them over with
um but I knew that was a bigger amount
then I was gonna be able to get over
with in a minute or two so I had to
learn to be patient and and kind of
follow the process and not try to get
ahead of myself yeah cool very cool you
guys great job excellent we're proud of
you you're amazing I mean in your 50s
your baby steps Millionaire's house and
everything's paid for you know making
180 you can do anything you want to do
now what's the first big thing you're
going to do now that you're dead free
well the first thing was coming here but
um we have some plans to do quite a bit
more traveling this year so
um now that we can go back into Canada
we're going to Canada fishing for a week
and there you go doing some fun stuff
like that there you go good that's a
good trip very cool good stuff good
stuff all right bring the kiddos up
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you a copy of Total
Money Makeover for you and a Financial
Peace University membership for you you
can use those or give them that's the
live and give box so what are the kiddos
names in ages kiddos they're like adults
teenagers
this is my son-in-law Wendell her
daughter Ashley and our daughter Carson
sorry are you all Tina are the team
what's ages
um Ashley's 25 Carson's 18. okay very
cool well congratulations you guys very
well done we are proud of your parents
too so yeah they are Randy and Audra
Carson Ashley and Wendell Milwaukee
Wisconsin area 130 000 paid off in 29
months making 140 to 180 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that is how it's done
it is interesting that
um you get new information and some
people act on it and some people don't
yeah I mean depending on probably how
um where you are in your financial
journey and for them it was retirement
he's like I don't want to look up and
sell this house at retirement so you
know so there's usually that why what's
that thing that's kind of that motivator
so uh but the fact that I love even just
with the numbers on my man they did so
well
uh with being wise with it and they did
it in you know a little over two years
where we say on average it takes about
seven years to pay off the whole house
but as they've been chipping away at it
throughout you know their Journey being
able just to like for two years just
really focus in you get that result and
and now you get to live with no payments
yeah I like it that she dropped that
podcast on him didn't even know what he
was getting into made it his idea yeah
pretty great that's what we tell because
a lot of spouses you know or people we
talk to married couples one of the
biggest questions is my spouse won't get
on board and we say one of the ways is
to have a third party be the one to
deliver the message so whether it's
through a book or through a podcast so
all you spouses out there or that want
that want this plan but maybe your other
spouse has a tent they're a great
picture of hey just give them some
information and let us be the bad guys
and give them what they need it's great
it's our spiritual gift this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today folks a
lot of you got questions about taxes
because it's tax time we get it taxes
are confusing
to help you get a better handle on them
let's unpack a question from one of our
listeners Dave my son has got a W-2 from
his first job this year he's 18 and
still in high school does he have to
file separately your son will need to
file a separate tax return if his earned
income was more than twelve thousand
nine hundred fifty dollars
the good news is you can still claim him
as a dependent on your tax return as
long as he indicates that someone else
is claiming him as a dependent on his
return he can do all of that and get all
of his refund money back as well which
you'll probably get a hundred percent of
it back so to claim adult children as
dependents they have to live with you
for more than half of that year they
must be under age 19 at the end of the
tax year or under age 24 and a full-time
student they must file single not
jointly and you must provide more than
50 percent of their financial support
for expenses like housing food clothing
and so forth that's the IRS rules if
you're ready to file your taxes check
out Ramsey smart tax it lets you file
online with upfront low pricing no
hidden fees and you can save up to 70
percent when you switch from another
software and we won't try to sell you a
credit card like termitex so check it
out go to ramseysolutions.com smart tax
it's quick it's it's easy also at
ramseysolutions.com if you're since
we're up on tax time if you need a tax
professional because you've got a
complicated return we have a group of
endorsed local providers around the
nation just click on ELP for taxes at
ramseysolutions.com and we'll help you
find that as well all right let's go to
Paul in Kansas City hey Paul welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey David Rachel thank you for taking my
call sure my wife and I would like to
build a new home and we would like your
advice in regards to the financial
implications of building that new home
we currently own our home and we are
trying to figure out whether it makes
sense to sell our home and rent a place
for a period of time and and pay for the
home with cash
or if it made more sense to to borrow a
sum of money uh temporarily well and
continue to live in our home while the
new home is being built
um we've followed your you know
debt-free philosophy and it's been a
great inspiration for us so it it feels
um strange or odd to us to to be
borrowing money again but um just
wondering if you thought that made sense
maybe in this particular case
well obviously you'd just be doing it
for a very short period of time until
you're home sold
okay I agree
um so neither one of these uh fall in a
in a dumb column we would not click dumb
or check dumb beside you on either one
of these both of them are fine you're
going to end up at the end of the story
with a paid for house am I understanding
that correct
correct okay so a couple of just
comments one is uh
uh
be careful of and almost write it down
and both of you sign it that were not
keeping
this house
that you live in now no matter what
we're selling it
because I don't want you to get into
this and go well you know I think we'll
ran that
I think we want to I saw something on
Tic Tac and I want to be a landlord now
I I don't want you you know going
sideways on this and that can happen
that can happen often and uh so you have
to be both of you have to be full my
brother wants to live in I don't care
okay you are selling this freaking house
you got to have that kind of mentality
you with me and nothing sneaks up on you
nothing changes that if you go this way
so that's comment number one comment
number two is I don't borrow money for
anything ever and so were I in your
situation I would have to move into a
rental
because I wouldn't even borrow the short
term because I simply am never going
into debt again ever for anything even
if it costs me inconvenience even if it
costs me money
because I don't borrow money period and
that has served me really really well
that's caused me to be able to prosper
and to avoid risk and downturns and
pandemics and everything else
and so um so yeah so there's this extra
cost in the moving and then the hassle
pain in the butt but at the end of the
day there's no Bank transaction you're
not dealing with all that right so so
there's a freedom there that you carry
through this whole process but Paul if
you do choose and again like Dave just
said there's no stupid quote-unquote box
to check here on either one but also a
risk that we see people whether it's oh
we're not going to end up selling the
house we're going to end up renting it
or whatever they go off on that or the
loan as you start building and my
husband and I we built in 2019
and slowly man the the upgrades oh we
could do these kind of cabinets this
um you want those fixture as well you
could oh that but like that fixture is
just a little bit more and you start
Crea it's like the lifestyle creep but
it's the house creep and then you can
kind of start to justify well we'll just
take out like 50 000 more and pay it but
you know we'll just take out a little
bit more to get what we want you start
to just move that Finish Line when debt
and alone is part of it it's hard to
have this more black and white stance
that when it's just cash so if you guys
do stay in your home take out a loan to
build again just as just as passionately
as you are that you're going to sell the
house you have to be as passionate with
this as our number and we're sticking to
it no matter what because
it it is hard and trust me it's not fun
when you're like oh I'm building a house
and this and we have to cut stuff
remember we got to do that we had to
look at our budget came over budget and
it was like you have to cut stuff and
it's just it's not fun to go backwards
when you have your dream you're like oh
man we can't have all of this so we have
to cut things and when it's with cash it
is what it is versus okay we don't have
the money we can't yeah you just you
don't and so versus the loan you can
kind of be in that gray so just be
careful just words of caution Paul yeah
you're when you're borrowing money
Rachel's point is you're more apt to
have scope creep on the size of the
build than you are when you're using
real cash
because real cash runs out eventually
and so um and that's a very that's a
very wise Insight good very good
Jonathan's with us in Gainesville
Florida hey Jonathan how are you
hey I'm doing well you all doing all
right better than we deserve what's up
so um
never really done Ramsey before but also
never had debt uh but we're we've gotten
to a point where I'm considering
a new car and I just uh y'all are about
the most conservative on this I just
want to run the numbers with you and
it's scaring me a little bit but it
might be an okay decision and if if Jade
of all people
gives me the green light I'll feel
better about it
all right how much are you going to buy
uh so it's a 36 or 37 000 Tacoma
for my wife
um after a tax tag out the door it's
like 40 or 41. that's not a new that's
used
no it's brand new I got one is your net
worth is your net worth over a million
dollars
yeah I'm sorry
no sir okay are you paying cash
yes sir okay what's your household
income
uh 80.
I live on 40.
and we invest save and how do I do other
stuff with the other 40. okay the rule
of thumb that we use
is don't buy a total of everything that
you own that has wheels and motors
because everything that's wheels and
Motors goes down in value don't buy more
than half your annual income total so
unless you're walking that's why I feel
a little unless you're walking yeah
you just spent 36 unless you're walking
she's not getting this car
gotcha but I have to meet the half I
have part of it too would be so she just
got in a car crash and so we've got an
inflow of of money from hers and then I
have a second car that she's driving now
it won't work that we're going to sell
no matter what and so between well
either I get her you know another beater
that we just put so much in the tires no
you don't have to do that you just don't
go buy a new car go buy a 20 000 truck
for her get her a twenty thousand dollar
Tacoma tacos are great we've had a bunch
of tacos that's what we call them in our
family uh when When Rachel he was
driving a taco
Winston's drove a Tacoma most of his
life yep when I met him
until he went yep he went full size it
was a big deal
but Tacoma we like the tacos they do
keep the rally so they they are well
they better they like nothing keeps its
value but yeah yeah get a used one that
you can afford don't buy new cars unless
you have a net worth of a million
dollars and don't buy cars that total
over a half a half your annual income so
yeah don't buy this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
wave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships open phones
here at triple eight eight two five five
two two five Rachel Cruz Ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones here again triple eight eight two
five five two two five before we jump at
the calls just a reminder that our
Ramsey Solutions headquarters just south
of Nashville and Franklin Tennessee are
open to the public there's a bit of a
museum there's a bookstore there's a
wonderful coffee shop the cookies are
homemade and free the coffee is
wonderful and free and we do this show
from one to four central time every
Monday through Friday live on the glass
a couple of rams and personalities will
be sitting here all of those days unless
it's a holiday of some kind we were not
here for instance on Good Friday the
whole company was closed as an example
but otherwise we're here and typically
there's uh 50 to 200 people sitting out
here watching the show uh as we do it
and you're more than welcome it's all
the whole experience is completely our
gift to you and we'd love to have you
anytime so just put us on your list on
this Friday tomorrow for most of you
listening we'll be broadcasting live
from the Ramsey Live Events Center as we
go into smart conference weekend
and uh so we're doing that from the
stage there with about a thousand folks
or so maybe 1500 whatever it ends up
being in the live audience there and
we'll be taking questions from the floor
as well as uh over the phones um for
those of you tuning in to that
particular uh event or that particular
podcast or whatever however it is you
get to show so thank you thank you thank
you thank you again open phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Trish is in Coeur d'Alene Idaho hi Trish
how are you
hey Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up
good well I have a question I'll jump
right to it my father-in-law passed away
a year and a half ago and my husband and
his two sisters are the beneficiaries of
his estate
um the one sister has been listed as the
executor
um and it took us until about a month
ago to even get a copy of his will
they claim that all of his assets have
been sold or gotten rid of or whatever
but they won't provide any accounting of
it and the only thing left is he had a
quite a gun collection that he was very
proud of and that was a big part of his
life and that he shared with his
children as far as an interest and love
of guns
so now these uh executor of the sister
is insisting that these guns are going
to be sold on Saturday at a sale and
she's telling us that if we want to have
any of these guns that we have to pay
the price that she has listed them at we
have been through Financial Peace
University we're in baby step two we
have forty thousand dollars left of debt
to pay off and we have gotten fed up
with debt and we are at the point that
we don't borrow money
but as being in baby step two we only
have a thousand dollars in our emergency
fund and we just feel really stuck why
is his sister being a butt
I don't know I feel like they are hiding
things
and um and I don't know why well they
not get along I mean your brother your
husband I get along with the sisters
they get along just fine except when
somebody died they did the same thing
when their mother passed away
but we're really torn that we have three
grown children
um two of them are sons and they would
really like to have some of these guns
of course they mean a lot to my husband
but financially we can't justify going
into debt to acquire these guns
I've reached out to like five or six or
two one-third of the guns are yours or
your husband correct
yes and that's what the will States is
that these assets are to do be divided
in the third okay so as he told her no
has he told her you're not selling a
third of them I will come pick them up
yes and that was met with this
conversation was over and she hung up on
it okay if I were your husband I would
call it depends on how much you want to
do you got two choices okay you stand
back and watch this happen or you hire
an attorney and you stop the sale and
you sue her ass
yeah
but then if we get go to the attorney
route I mean that's a lot of money too
no it's not
won't take a lot because this all this
woman needs is somebody just to give her
uh get her attention
that's what she needs no one has stood
up to this woman in a long time
and it is time somebody did okay but for
real though how much will it cost to get
an attorney to Trisha's point you know
it costs 200 to go get a letter and tell
her we're gonna you know might cost a
thousand dollars to file with the
probate court and stop the sale
but all you got to have is an attorney
listen all you got to have is an
attorney call her and this whole thing
is going to stop because she's she's
gonna cave like like a Walmart tent
I mean okay
it's never gone through probate
it doesn't have to necessarily
she has to follow you know the executor
is to follow the execution of the will
does the will state that the assets are
all to be sold at auction
to sell assets to pay those debts and
anything that's left to divide them
equally by the three children okay but
we don't know if there's debt left
well she won't say anything
on two other properties that have been
sold got no accounting of that either
yes so it just depends on how you know
you either can just forget it and walk
away
and just forget it it's probably not a
lot of money it's probably not a lot of
money
well the
best it's not a lot of money
yeah forty thousand dollars divided by
three is not much
it's not going to pay for the attorney
by the time you have a big old fight
so you just got to decide how pissed you
are about this
well you're twisted up is your husband
oh my husband's emotionally Iraq okay I
mean like a wuss wreck or like a guy
who's gonna stand up and do something
about it
well that's more what I'm afraid of
do something about do something about it
hire an attorney and shut her down put
them in junk go into a probate court put
an injunction on the sale until there's
an accounting of this stuff and that
because these assets need to be divided
if you want to spend a little money
fighting on it fight on it
but but it's more about the fight than
it is and the Injustice of the situation
that is the actual amount of money
because I don't think there's a lot of
money here kiddo
no there's not but when we live our life
by saying we're not going to take out
any more debt ever yeah um and she's we
feel like we're being put in a position
where we have to real things you don't
you don't have to accept her terms I
don't have to accept her terms
okay just because you're going to get
some money from this estate and you can
pay the attorney with that money
there's money due to you there's money
due to your husband I know
yes and you don't know how much Trish no
we don't but no we don't know do you
have a reasonable get okay what do you
think this property was worth is sold
he sold his house for 158 000 that's all
before he died by a few years
and then he owned another piece of
property that um conveniently got sold
to one of the sisters
[Music]
okay you you you've either got to decide
you're going to accept this situation
you've got hire an attorney this
afternoon
and you have to file with a probate
court to stop the sale tomorrow until
the executor is held to account
to an accounting of where the money is
freaking gone that's what I would do
because I don't put up with this trash
and this is just trash this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you're planning a move anytime soon
that's awesome we're excited for you but
uh in some places around the country
you're still going to be facing some
high home prices and interest rates well
they haven't gone down to their record
lows either that doesn't make home
ownership impossible if you want to buy
or sell you just got to make sure you're
financially ready and you've got to have
a trusted and experienced real estate
agent to walk you through it not a
family friend who got their license last
month not someone who does Real Estate
as a hobby you need a pro especially in
times like these you can find a high
octane High Caliber high protein Ramsey
trusted agent like that
through our endorsed local providers
program and since we vet the agents from
around the country we have the best
support and uh we're gonna if you're
moving from Florida to Alaska or vice
versa we can help you wherever it is
wherever it is ramseysolutions.com Agent
and find a Ramsey trusted real estate
agent today that's ramseysolutions.com
slash
agent
okay let's um
go back for a second to the last call
yeah it was a it was a good one yeah
it's in a way I felt terrible for her
really bad one in another way so
number one
everyone needs a will
number two the executor of the will the
word executor literally means execute
they are to execute
the document what the document says they
do not have leeway
to get creative
the executor has to follow the
guidelines of the will
and
that apparently was being done we don't
know for sure except for the part where
she's selling the guns and as being a
butt to her brother
okay that's the technical legal part of
of having will everyone needs a will and
everyone needs an Executor in the will
now how do you prevent something like
this from happening dad that died bless
his heart
southern term did a did a crummy job
because his job is not to let his death
and his little
not a lot of assets
I mean there's less than a hundred
thousand dollars in play here by the
time they divide it up and go through
all the garbage 30 grand a piece
probably yeah so this is not like these
people are getting rich out of this
thing
so all they did was get mad at each
other for Life over a handful of guns
really that's pretty hillbilly and so
you really need to sit down with the
people that are going to be handling the
will and be very clear what you want
done and the spirit over which you want
this done the purpose of me leaving my
three children something if I'm this man
is for them to have a quality
relationship When the Smoke Clears
you can't tell unless this guy's some
kind of weirdo that died he doesn't want
his three kids not speaking each other
right right you don't want them mad at
each other and that's what he got okay
but my question was let's just
keep going with it if he's no his job
was to do a reading of the will while
he's Alive cover it with the three kids
here's what I want done here's how I
want to do yeah but can't she older
sister still like I know she can't but
she still could be hey even if all
that's done if he had done that all but
and then all the kids but at least then
the other sister wouldn't have
participated you know I mean let's just
ended up with the land
in the deal that's right okay that's
right because there was another piece
because I was gonna say if but but
there's some Dynamic going on in the
family here that was there before he
died but you have to sell those assets
in order to pay off debt so my question
is what if there was more debt in the
sister has to sell the guns because it's
the only assets took the land yeah and
so she doesn't have a choice well no you
can't you can't get to the you know you
no I mean if you sell Assets in order to
pay off the debt so what if there was
more important but if what if the other
sister took more than her third or
didn't you know more than her third net
in that land that's what we don't know
we don't know we don't have an
accounting so in this case but what
happened is how do you prevent something
that's happening is you sit down with
the all three kids in the room together
when you do the will and you say Sally's
going to be the executor but here's
what's going to happen Sally this is
what you're going to do
and the other two understand what she's
going to do and if she doesn't do that
now the last piece of this is you don't
wait
when things are misbehaving for a year
and a half you don't wait till two days
before the gun sail to decide to be mad
you get mad like months ago
from our caller I think she was mad I
think she's gonna say I don't know what
to do her husband wouldn't do anything
about it so you know what but you got to
decide okay I'm going to force this hand
a long time before two days before this
right right you can't wait up until the
last minute because that just adds even
more drama to the whole situation so two
months ago go over to your sister's
house sit down and go look you're going
to provide an accounting or we're going
to take you to court and the Court's
going to tell you you're going to
provide an accounting you're going to
have to you're gonna have to own up fess
up to what's going on here you don't get
to do this in the dark that's not how
this works and if you don't then that's
what we're going to do and you just you
just solve it you just tell people this
is the way it is there's two options
you're going to provide an accounting
easy or you're going to provide an
accounting hard you got that aside and
and you know hang up on me if you want
but try hanging up on the judge he'll
put you in jail so it's called contempt
of court so you don't want to do that
that's this is ridiculous so but what
happens is all this drama happens
because of poor planning and a poor
process in place we're putting a poor
executor in right because you can do all
of that but if you know your oldest
daughter Sally's a little cray-cray
don't put her as the executor exactly
exactly oldest daughter doesn't
necessarily mean you get to do it
cray-cray invalidates yeah
yeah
this is you lose your license you lose
your executor's license okay that's as
if there is such a thing that's a real
thing Tony's in Winston-Salem hey Tony
how are you
I am well thank you good how can we help
I am I work full-time for the state of
North Carolina I'm retiring in three
years
um I have been doing a side hustle for
the last several years as a real estate
agent and I plan to transition to that
full-time my husband and I are in baby
steps six we have been fully focused on
paying off our home but I'm wondering if
maybe we should maybe back off that a
little bit in start stockpiling cash for
our Hill and Valley account for when I
transitioned to real estate full-time
how much are you making in your current
job working for the state
not uh 82. and how much were you making
on real estate even though it's just a
side thing but
I made 52 last year okay good for you
thank you
well I think the the biggest thing how
much is in your emergency fund
uh 32.
32 000.
when do you want to quit
2026.
I don't think you need to do anything if
you want to pile up some extra money
that's fine but by 2026 you're probably
going to be making more in real estate
than you are now
and that'll be me that'll mean you mean
you'll be making more than your or at
your job now so it's not going to be an
issue
okay I just I know
I had a slow first quarter and it got me
just thinking you know I need to be able
to cover my bills when when I don't have
my full-time job to fall back on
this last quarter was a slow first
quarter yeah I mean because real estate
slowed down okay
um I mean you could have a separate
little account Tony and just say hey
here's an here's an additional two
months to get me through but it's not
like you're gonna make nothing I mean if
you go full time into real estate
you're probably going to have some
backlog from the year before when you
decide to quit so what's your husband
Mike
he's retired uh he got Social Security
because like 12 15 000 a year okay
yeah I'd probably try to slow down on
the house a little bit I don't want you
to get into retirement and still have
debt on the house because of this
routine but
um but I mean per like 65 years old and
still have that on the house okay how
much is left but that's that's what I
would do I would just move that
direction and I think you're in better
shape than you feel like you are you're
a fairly conservative person
and um but another thirty thousand bucks
or so set aside I think you'd be in good
shape to move on out and head that right
way it's great Tony congratulations
doing it part time making 52. yeah
that's really that's that's respectable
that's solid uh and that gives you you
know you got the boat close to the dock
before you jump off you know a lot of
times people don't get the boat close
enough to dock they don't make enough at
the side hustle and it's just like a
dream and then they just jump and they
miss and they get in the water so you've
done a really good job of getting that
income up good good job this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today Madison
is on the debt-free stage in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions hey Madison how are
you I'm doing well how are you better
than I deserve where do you live I live
in Frederick Maryland oh good to have
you okay and how much debt have you paid
off a hundred and forty eight thousand
good for you and how long did this take
uh three years good for you and your
range of income during that time um it
went from about 38 000 to now about a
hundred and or 145 000. oh my God nice
job Madison thing wow what do you do for
a living now uh now I work as a
procurement manager at a biotechnology
company very cool what did you do before
um so I took the first job that came
available out of college and I worked in
claims okay and then just boom rocket
shipped up huh yes good for you so what
kind of debt was your 148 000. um it was
a mortgage you paid off your house how
old are you I'm 25.
wow what is this house worth
um now it's about 300 000. oh my gosh
look at that
well done Madison thank you well done
what caused you to do this as a 25 year
old because you were 22 when you started
this so you got out of college bought a
house and just said I'm gonna just do
what I can to pay it off yeah so and
actually in 2017 my parents had bribed
me to go to a financial peace course at
the church with them
um so they were going through the
process
um so I watched them get debt free and
then getting out of school I decided to
just go for it and as my income inclined
I get to keep putting more and more
towards it so
just a financial peace baby going crazy
yeah
wow
so cool so incredible I bet they're
doing double back flips oh yeah
oh yeah good job so great Madison
best money you ever spent bribing that
kid to go to FPU they never paid it but
it was it was a carrot that was never
eaten we dangled the carrot and we never
got the carrot I never went back for it
oh wow there's got to be some kind of
payback on that I mean there's something
something big I'm just saying wow that's
so cool very very cool man so I mean you
know how weird you are right uh yes yes
because I mean like all your friends oh
gosh yes it's it's very odd talking to
them now when they're all going into
um it's the time of the lake they're all
buying houses so having mine paid off
you're like an old person
Financial person a financial old person
as a 22 year old 23 24 25 like during
those early 20s right did you feel like
you were sacrificing a ton to do this
like would you look back and be like it
was really hard I wanted there was stuff
I wanted to do and I did it or are you
like I was just young and kind of still
looked like I was in college and just
honestly they kept going that was the
key to it is um I lived on that income
that I had already been living off of um
I really didn't up what I was doing
um personally yeah I did I lived with my
parents for longer um and I think that
that was the main sacrifice was not
moving out at the time that everyone
else my age was
um but that ultimately led to this so
great and that's one of the pros when we
talk to young people that do this is
there there's this idea that you know
you you came from call you know you got
out of college and like you said it's
not like you had to go majorly backwards
in lifestyle versus people that are
doing it you know in their 30s 40s and
50s which is so great but they feel this
like oh my gosh I have to to go
backwards in what we were doing we have
to feel that sacrifice but for you
you're like I'm going to just stay
consistent of what how I've been living
as a 21 year old yeah
which is such a pro so young people
listening like it is it not only is it
smart to do it as early as possible but
also I don't think you
um feel that like oh my gosh we used to
do this and now I can't because you're
like I'm still living like I'm 21 and
I'm gonna freaking pay off my house so
well done what's the house worth
um now it's about 300. it's about 300
okay great job good for you that's
awesome and and you and you make 145 000
a year and you don't have a payment in
the world yep how does that feel it
feels great it feels great to be able to
move to the next steps of life and and
not have that burden on my shoulders and
know that I will will have that burden
in the future so what was your degree in
economics so have you sat down and done
the math of how rich you're going to be
yeah because it's scary it's scary yeah
so I mean it's scary if you start
putting away like three or four thousand
bucks a month right now which would
still leave you a hundred grand to live
on I mean you're gonna have tens of
millions of dollars I mean it's
unbelievable how compound interest at 25
years old it's going to blow up yeah I
think we did the math based on right now
if my income never changed and it was
about 30 million
um just based on what I was investing
it's such a mature move I mean it just
speaks a lot to who you are in your
character and as a young person you're
like man you know you're just making
really long term decisions with your
money and a lot and and again it's kind
of that YOLO mentality that I feel like
a lot of Our Generation lives in and so
it speaks a lot to you uh and who you
are so I just think it's absolutely
incredible and you're gonna do
incredible stuff with that money you
know that part of Building Wealth is to
be able to be generous and help people
and that and I just I feel that off of
you I feel like you're just such a kind
kind person so I'm I'm just so happy for
you and thank you I appreciate it that's
great it's absolutely fabulous okay
so um gen Z and the Millennials are
listening
there's a poster child right here 25
years old with a paid for house it's
worth three hundred thousand dollars
making 148. we've done the math it's
going to be a 30 million dollar minimum
is where we're going to end up
um and they look at you and they say
okay how did you get out of debt what is
the key
to getting out of debt yeah um so I
would say consistency and then
remembering to celebrate the little
goals
um my family and I actually built a
paper chain around our office with a
thousand dollar links and so every time
I paid off certain amount we would cut
these links off and then when we got to
large Milestones like 50 000 we would
celebrate
um I think that was really important to
visualize the end goal and see it coming
to fruition yeah yeah you got to have
the that sense of traction is a
psychological thing that you really
can't get away from you've got to have
this sense of progress a sense of
direction because otherwise to sacrifice
um to live like no one else is just
mentally ill I mean you're just doing
you're just doing it because it hurts I
mean that's dumb you know so you don't
want to do that you wouldn't do it it's
okay if it hurts but it hurts so that
you know I'm gonna say no so I never
have to say no I'm going to live like no
one else so that later I can live and
give like no one else no discipline
seems Pleasant at the time but it yields
a harvest of righteousness you are
incredible what hero wow that is so
powerful what a great great lesson I
just wrote an op-ed that will be posted
on Fox in about a week I guess and they
had asked me to write about gen Z and
Millennials and the number that a number
of them that are um living off their
parents income they're being supported
by their parents still at 30 years old
and 28 years old and this kind of stuff
and of course they were after me
trashing them and I I don't trash gen Z
and Millennials because I find too many
of them like you
um I got I got about 400 of them working
here and they're like you and so uh to
trash the entire generation based on a
couple of participation trophy people
it's just it's irresponsible and not
accurate and so there's too many of them
like you that are amazing and um so
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for standing up you give old people
great hope that America is going to be
okay people like you tell me it's gonna
be okay we're gonna be all right there's
a whole bunch of her out there people
I'm just saying Madison from Frederick
Maryland we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires I think we're gonna have to
do the billionaire version for you but
the uh and Total Money Makeover for you
as well and uh Financial Peace
University membership you'll probably
give all those away but you may read the
millionaire one if you haven't so the
live and give box just for you saying
thanks for coming all the way from
Maryland you are an impressive
impressive young woman absolutely
fabulous Madison from Frederick Maryland
148 000 paid off in three years making
38 to 145 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one I'm done
free
and everything at 25 years old just shut
up wow all amazing
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
our scripture today First Corinthians 12
12.
a body though one has many parts but all
its many parts form one body
so it is with Christ
Steve Jobs said great things in business
are never done by one person they're
done by a team of people this is true
today's Ramsey Show question of the day
is sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services it's spring cleaning time
and the neighbor and neighborly is the
best place to find great services to
help you Spruce things up like Molly
made the ground skies and Junk King
start your search for Reliable experts
near you at neighborly.com today's
question comes from Cindy in Nevada I'm
happy to say that we are enjoying baby
steps seven Building Wealth and giving I
do have a few close friends who
frequently criticize me for not having a
credit card only a debit card they tell
me I'm putting myself at high risk for
fraud and that I am not protected can
you please clarify how a debit card is
safe
uh well this is a common misconception
when it comes to credit card or to debit
cards so the best way to do it is when
you run your debit card is to hit
actually credit and sign your name
versus Hit debit and do your PIN number
because when you hit credits it's not a
credit card it's still coming out of
your account as a debit card but it's
run through the same system as it would
a credit card so you get all of the
protections that a credit card would
have but you're having it with a debit
card so it is a safe they they will have
the same protection policy with your
debit card
and um so Cindy uh
uh
uh are you gonna tell her to get new
friends how to say this yeah no no I'm
not but um
you are wealthy
you have no debt
you have control of your money you're
incredibly generous you should be
telling other people how to handle their
money not broke people telling you how
to handle money that's good and so you
know just I mean I they are not on a
credible footing to tell you anything
about anything
money-wise
um and so but here's the deal if you
want to
I don't argue with people like this I
just ignore them but including the ones
in my personal life okay so it's just
you know whatever you want to do do it
um but if you want if you personally
want to understand just go to visa.com
or mastercard.com they have in their
fine print that you can look in the card
member agreement there's a paragraph
that says zero liability policy and the
zero liability policy that says that in
the event your card is misused debit or
credit fraudulent transactions you are
responsible for zero
period they have a zero liability policy
the customer is not responsible in a
debit card use with Mastercard or VISA
in their own terms and conditions on
their website is not responsible for a
penny
so you earn zero at risk more using a
debit card than you are using a credit
card that is absolutely false
it is a it's mythology that the debit
card is more dangerous the only
difference is if you if I use my debit
card at a hotel and a hotel uh clerk
steals the number
writes it down while there you have got
my card or something and then they go
and buy something that night with it and
they run it and my my bank doesn't catch
it and it comes out of my account it
might be a day or two before they put
the money back
that's the only difference
and I have never had that happen and I
have been using debit cards since the
day they came out and have not had a
credit card in 35 years
and I walk the earth
just fine and I know we kind of rag on
banks a lot but I'll say I'll be honest
the bank I have with my debit card
they're so on it with fraud charges like
they will probably wear me out yes but I
like it because I'm like thank you for
at least being on top of it and
thankfully none of it is it's all my
transactions well they wear you out
because it's their money that they're
gonna lose yeah but they're at least on
it it's most banks are on it which is
great they're fraud algorithms on on
credit or debit uh most of most of us
and they're walking around in America
today get a call a week or a call every
two weeks of some kind is this just
really your charge and so like I have to
tell them if I'm going out of the
country Sharon or going on vacation
don't deny all our charges you know
which is good though I know I know but
it's not the point it's a pain in the
butt but that is because the bank knows
that visa and MasterCard says they are
liable not you
and so you are not at risk of losing
substantial sums of money or any sum of
money due to fraud or any kind of high
risk activity so your friends are just
wrong
it's that simple they just don't know
what they're talking about now again how
forceful you want to be with that
argument or how much you just personally
want to be comfortable with the idea is
fine I have a bunch of friends that use
a credit card and paid off every month
and they have a lot of money and um and
they just you know and and some of them
probably believe this crap but I just
don't have this discussion with them I'm
not going to talk to them about it I
carry a debit card there's not a chance
I have a credit card under any situation
ever again I am not going to ever be in
debt especially to a stupid Bank all
right Mary's with us in Charlotte North
Carolina hey Mary welcome to the Ramsay
show
thank you Dave how you doing today great
how can we help
so I have a quick question
um some baby step two
and I have I really want to pay off
sixty thousand dollars worth of credit
card debt that I have by the end of this
year
um good and
yeah that's the goal so the question
that I have is my husband's through his
employer he has 401k and you know he has
been contributing on that and I was
wondering should we just leave it as is
or
um should he not so that we can go ahead
and make more payments towards that debt
that we have
yeah we all want to yeah pause that and
you're going to want to throw everything
at this credit card debt what caused you
guys to go 62 000 in credit card debt
well part of it was medical okay
um unfortunately we have I've got two
girls and they were very sick
um I'm sorry so yeah
um
yeah I'm also that and I we like I said
one baby stuff too so I still have car
loans to pay off and obviously the
mortgage
when we are teaching the baby steps in
the book The Total Money Makeover
now and and when you hear us talk about
this stuff when we say stay baby step
two 100 of the time we tell everyone to
stop all investing temporarily so you
can exclusively focus on getting out of
debt
and we also tell them to take every dime
out of any non-retirement Investments
and non-retirement savings except for a
thousand dollars and throw that at their
debt snowball how much do you have in
savings
so we've been throwing everything so the
only thing that I have is the one
thousand dollars emergency fund you
don't have any mutual funds or any
savings account that is not that one
thousand dollars
no just the 401K that he has good well
that that part you have correct then and
then we would tell you even though
you're missing the match it's a
temporary thing it's only for a year or
less because you need to get out of debt
and we're totally focusing on the debts
we're temporarily stopping now that
feels uncomfortable it feels almost like
you're missing out on free money and all
that because I love a match on a 401K I
think it's wonderful but but right now
the power of focus the power of all in
the power of passion of for getting out
of debt supersedes that match
so temporarily and again the word is
temporarily we're not doing this for
very long but for temporarily we're
going to stop all investing and attack
this with a Vengeance hang on I'm going
to have Austin send you a copy of the
book The Total Money Makeover you and
your husband read the whole book and
they'll show you exactly what to do with
these baby steps it's exactly it's the
handbook for baby steps that's what it
is and it'll help you do that so good
show today Rachel yep it's been great so
tomorrow and the weekends will be so fun
with smart conference smart conference
on the hill and live broadcast on the
hill at the Nash at the Nashville the
Ramsey Event Center this weekend and
tomorrow we'll be doing the show from
the stage there Austin Ben James Zack
and Andrew good job in the booth the
booth dudes they pulled it off again
that puts this hour in the books we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]